bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro de ski mag quel
est le rôle de départements dans le
quotidien des saint quentinois 20
millions d'euros vient d'être allouée
cas le contrat yvelines territoire ceci
afin de financer des projets
structurants dans six domaines clés je
vous propose d'en faire le tour
c'est parti
[Musique]
et
quelles sont les actions du conseil
départemental qui impacte la vie des
habitants
ces derniers en août et une vague idée
nous sommes allés nous renseigner pour
être honnête
absolument pas c'est surtout ce qui est
laid les collèges tout ce qui l'aide
sociale je pense au collège je pense aux
routes
tout est fait pour les ja développer la
mobilité douce peut-être qu'ils
subventionnent certains transports en
commun j'ai aucune idée de
l'intervention d'un département
pas si simple donc mais pas de panique
on va vous expliquer pour compenser les
baisses importantes de moyens publics
une agglomération comme saint-martin est
obligé bien sûr de s'organiser et de et
d'anticiper on a la chance d'avoir des
partenaires puissants c'est le cas de
l'europe qui qui qui nous aide c'est le
cas de la région ile de france nous aide
c'est le cas du département des yvelines
le département des yvelines je souhaite
particulièrement être proche des grands
projets yvelinois et dans ce cadre là il
s'est bien sûr rapprocher des
différentes territoire par le biais bien
sûr des intercommunalités pour pouvoir
mieux comprendre les attentes bien sûr
des élus du territoire dans le cadre de
la politique contractuelle le contrat
yvelines territoire a été impulsé pour
six ans à hauteur de 150 millions
d'euros pour l'ensemble des départements
un contrat spécifique aux yvelines pour
soutenir ces territoires stratégiques
dont saint quentin en yvelines
l'agglomération représentent plus de 30%
de l'emploi du département est donc le
premier pôle économique le soutien de sa
compétitivité est l'une des priorités du
département et ce à travers plusieurs
axes les axes importants
ça va être certes le développement
économique en direct mais son site tout
ce qui favorise le développement
économique c'est à dire les transports
en particulier transport collectif en
site propre c'est aussi la formation ça
va être le numérique c'est aussi des
infrastructures routières pour permettre
de rentrer et sortir de saint quentin en
yvelines
c'est plus qu'une négociation c'est
l'écriture à quatre mains saint quentin
en yvelines et le département d'un
projet commun de territoire pourquoi
parce que saint quentin et
et une pépite de la recherche française
et de la production de haute valeur
ajoutée à saint quentin on est dans
l'innovation et on travaille sur la
sécurité du futur on travaille sur
l'éducation du futur qui va être
un modèle je pense une agglomération qui
sera un modèle certainement france là
dessus sur la voiture du futur vous
aurez des voitures autonome dès 2010 950
1 sur le transport du futur avec un
projet de système semi aérien qu'on
présentera dans quelques mois
saint quentin en yvelines devrait
bénéficier de plus de 20 millions
d'euros de 2018 à 2021
afin de financer les projets
structurants nécessaires à son expansion
à commencer par la mobilité priorité à
l'amélioration des transports et à
l'accessibilité la desserte et le
maillage du territoire la création de la
société du grand paris et des lignes de
transport en commun que porte société du
grand paris
c'est une formidable opportunité pour la
métropole parisienne c'est un risque
pour les yvelines qui sont à la marge
nous aurons nous un petit bout de ce
grand réseau de transport la fameuse
ligne 18 dont on parle beaucoup à saint
quentin et que le département soutient
mais ça ne suffira pas parce que
justement nous sommes un peu éloigné et
il ne faudrait pas que nos sites
éloignés devenant moins compétitifs en
termes de temps de transport en soit
pénalisé plusieurs projets sont à
l'oeuvre parmi lesquels l'offre de
transport en commun en site propre le
tcsp ce site seront développées entre
les gares de la verrière et de trappes
et la gare de montigny le bretonneux les
franchissements de lax voie ferrée rn10
seront améliorés tout comme l'échangeur
entre la rn 12 et la venue des garennes
les axes de circulation douce eux seront
sécurisés innovation majeure pour le
territoire
les navettes supra ou est ce un projet
de transport autonome suspendu à
quelques mètres du sol une première
mondiale
l'étude du projet est d'ores et déjà
lancée
[Musique]
autre axe se développer par ce contrat
avec le département le développement
économique la rénovation urbaine et les
logements comme ici à trappes accroître
et diversifier l'offre de logement c'est
aussi l'objectif du contrat
départemental
ceci pour favoriser le parcours
résidentiel des saint quentinois et
permettre l'ancrage des salariés
habitant hors du territoire
le département souhaite mettre l'accent
sur le développement autour des pôles
gare et futur transport en site propre
le renforcement des centres villes et
les opérations de rénovation et de
requalification urbaine le
renouvellement de l'offre d'immobilier
d'entreprise représente l'autre enjeu
fondamental le but conserver les grands
acteurs économiques déjà présents et en
capter de nouveaux dans le cadre du
contrat yvelines territoire les zones
d'activités économiques vieillissante
seront requalifiés et repensé en quinze
ans de 2001 2014
le territoire a investi plus de 86
millions d'euros dans le cofinancement
des projets de rénovation urbaine
réalisée à saint quentin en yvelines
pour la période 2010 8 2024 de nouveaux
moyens vont permettre d'accroître ses
interventions dans les différents grands
ensembles des communes saint-quentinoise
depuis 2015 dans le cadre de priori
blinn 100 millions d'euros ont permis
l'engagement de vastes opérations
d'équipement et de restructuration du
parc de logements des quartiers
prioritaires
en parallèle le département souhaite
investir dans les collèges de ses
quartiers dans les cinq prochaines
années le but faire converger l'ensemble
des politiques publiques en faveur des
quartiers politique de la ville le
virage du numérique a été pris depuis
longtemps par l'agglomération celle ci
souhaite montrer l'exemple en matière de
formation et d'emploi
le département accompagnera le
développement de cette filière afin
d'augmenter l'attractivité du territoire
terre d'innovation oblige saint quentin
en yvelines se veut l'un des territoires
leader en matière du numérique
on essaie de combler ce déficit de
formation numérique que nous trouvons en
france le numérique se développe
beaucoup plus vite dans les entreprises
il ya un déficit de compétences donc il
faut que bien sûr les structures
publiques comme nous on accélère avec
l'université avec des formations privées
mais complémentaires il faut qu'on
accélère la culture numérique de nos
enfants de donner sens et nos adieux le
département souhaite encourager le
développement de ce secteur
il sentait cyber sécurité smart city
avec le schéma directeur d'aménagement
lumière accueille des entreprises tous
les domaines seront investis avec une
priorité pour l'éducation afin de
répondre aux métiers de demain
pour cela deux projets phares l'école du
numérique avec le développement d'outils
numériques à destination des écoles mais
aussi pour innover sur le plan des
apprentissages de l'accompagnement des
élèves et pour améliorer les relations
parents école et le campus numérique
conçue comme un hub d'orientation vers
les métiers de demain
l'objectif est d'améliorer
l'employabilité des saint quentinois
grâce à des formations innovantes et
d'anticiper les demandes des entreprises
[Musique]
les deux derniers volets concerne la
qualité de vie des habitants de
l'agglomération un environnement naturel
préservé une offre riche et varié dans
les domaines culturel et sportif ainsi
que les grands événements contribuent à
cette qualité de vie le but du
département est de préserver et
encourager ce cadre de vie
près de 5000 hectares de surfaces
végétalisée et 38 vassan de stockage
assure une protection naturelle contre
les changements climatiques
soixante dix mille arbres les parcs et
les forêts jouent un rôle de filtre
contre les particules fines
le contrat yvelines territoire
soutiendra les projets liés à la
préservation des paysages remarquables
et à la protection des espaces naturels
et agricoles
[Musique]
le domaine culturel l'offre et la
qualité des services renforcés par une
mise en réseau à l'échelle du territoire
se verra étoffé
[Musique]
mais un pôle sportif as c'est quand même
assez impressionnant puisque on a quand
même 4 4 sites olympiques
plus la ryder cup en septembre jack est
une grosse attractivité aussi sportive
ces événements permettent d'abord de
situer sur une carte
nous sommes à côté de paris notre
capitale est bien versailles et son
château et notre dynamisme économique se
trouve en propre à saint quentin en
yvelines dont qu'il s'agisse des jeux
olympiques il s'agit de la riderz cup
qu'il s'agisse du partenariat que nous
avec la société organisatrice du tour de
france et du paris nice tous ces grands
événements ont vocation à porter notre
image une image de dynamisme économique
et de qualité de vie incomparable point
de départ du paris brest paris depuis
1991 du paris nice depuis 2010 terre
d'accueil des championnats de france de
bmx en 2014 ou encore de championnats du
monde sur piste us ayant 2015 au
vélodrome nationale
saint quentin en yvelines et rodez à
l'organisation des grands événements
sportifs
en septembre prochain le territoire
accueillera la ryder cup de golf au golf
national
certaines épreuves des jeux olympiques
2024 se dérouleront aussi sur les sites
de l'agglomération
le cyclisme sur piste et sur route le
bmx et le vtt
le golf est l'épreuve des scream du
pentathlon moderne et à un
investissement qui rend un peu plus loin
c'est celui de la colline d'elancourt
c'est celui des jeux olympiques puisque
là on accompagnera pour les six ans qui
viennent un rayonnement international
bien au-delà des frontières de
l'agglomération le département
participera à l'aménagement de la
colline d'elancourt sites d'accueil des
épreuves de vtt
c'est un très beau travail c'est un très
gros investissement
d'ailleurs la lettre du département fait
partie il donne aussi une contribution
pour que nous aider à bien préparer et
réussir les jeux olympiques sont un
enjeu considérable pour tout le
département aussi
[Musique]
on est quand même dans une logique
positive d'investissement de création de
deux grands événements donc bientôt ça
donne du baume au coeur ça donne mais
aussi quand vos objectifs aussi élevés
bien entendu ccc entraînant on le voit
dans nos équipes qui sont effectivement
très motivé et en tout cas c'est comme
ça qu on obtient de bons résultats c'est
notre objectif d'être en france des gens
qui ont qui monte cette culture très
volontaire entrepreneuriale très porté
sur le aussi la production de richesse
de nouvelles solutions
les produits de demain il faut il faut
les brevets de demain il y en a beaucoup
qui se prépare ici l'argent que nous
récupérons nous le réinvestissons pour
avoir un cercle vertueux pour faire que
cet investissement attire des recettes
fiscales en créant de la richesse pour
qu'on puisse à nouveau investir
aujourd'hui rien ne se fait les uns sans
les autres
le territoire de saint quentin est un
territoire qui est au coeur du
département qui aujourd'hui est en
perpétuelle évolution
mais aussi également en maillage avec le
reste du territoire
le département ne peut pas faire sans
les agglomérations ni 150 ans et
réciproquement bien évidemment
[Musique]
vous savez désormais tout sur les
investissements du département pour
l'agglomération fiabilité à toutes et à
tous ciao
[Musique]